welcome back okay we're talking about
machine learning control and in
particular we're talking about how to
use genetic algorithms to tune the
parameters of a control log with a known
or specified structure so here what
we're gonna do is apply the genetic
algorithm to tune a PID controller in
MATLAB so here's just a quick recap of
the diagram so I have some PID
controller that I'm gonna wrap around my
system to obtain some desired objective
function I am representing the
parameters of this PID controller the
the proportional integral and derivative
terms as this kind of genetic sequence
of numbers and I'm going to try to find
the parameters these parameters that
optimize some objective function
basically finding these hotspots where
you get the best performance so we're
gonna have to define an objective
function we're going to have to
construct a kind of control law with
this the specified structure and then
we're going to use the MATLAB GA command
the genetic algorithm to tune these
parameters using this this evolutionary
strategy okay
so that's what we're doing right now I
want to caution you in real in real life
you don't want to use a genetic
algorithm to tune your PID controller
there's lots of other easier better ways
to tune this that would be less
expensive and you know simpler but this
is a demonstration of how you use the
MATLAB GA command for some kind of a
control optimization so this is an easy
one where there's three parameters we
want to optimize you could then take
that exact code and apply that to your
control system where you have parameters
that you want to optimize that's not a
PID controller okay so I don't want you
to think that this is you know only
useful or particularly useful for a PID
controller you can do this for for
anything where you know the basic
structure and you're just trying to
optimize the parameters so people have
done this tons using genetic algorithms
to optimize the parameters of a
structured control law okay
so we're actually going to do this in
MATLAB we're going to cook this up in
MATLAB and so what I'm going to do is a
few things I'm going to define a
system so I have to define some kind of
transfer function I'm going to do this
in the frequency domain so I'm gonna
define a transfer function I also have
to define some kind of an objective
function this is kind of my J function
it's a little hard to read but this is
my my J function and then what I'm going
to do is I'm going to wrap this GA
command around this okay so that's what
I'm gonna do so here's a script you can
download this the code will be online
this is in our book the book data driven
science and engineering okay so I clear
all close all CLC and to find a time
step I defined some basic parameters of
my genetic algorithm so I'm going to
iterate for ten generations and each
generation is going to have a population
size of 25 individuals okay so I'm gonna
have 25 individuals and I'm gonna enter
8 and advance that for 10 generations so
I wanted to find my system that I'm
going to be optimizing my PID around and
I'm going to start with just a transfer
function S as a transfer function s so
this establishes my Laplace variable s
in the frequency domain and my system is
G equals 1 over s times s times s plus s
plus 1 don't ask me why I chose this one
it probably has some interesting
properties so I have G equals 1 over s
times s squared plus s plus 1 ok that's
my transfer function that I'm going to
use 1 over s times s squared plus s plus
1 that's G and now I have to define some
objective function J so what I decided
to do is kind of this interesting hybrid
approach so I'm going to define my cost
function J my objective function to be
the lqr the linear quadratic regulator
cost function and I'm going to then find
PID control law that minimizes that lqr
cost ok so this is kind of weird hybrid
deal so here's the transfer function
this is my dynamical system it's just
some input/output system that has these
dynamics and I have this function called
PID test and what PID
test does is it takes in the dynamics G
the time step DT and a vector K of my
control lock proportional integral
derivative and it basically tests that
control law on that dynamical system
with this cost function that I'm going
to define so let me show you what PID
test n is so in PID test essentially
again this function takes in the dynamic
transfer function G a delta T and the
parameters of my my PID controller and
so basically it takes the first entry of
the parameters and that's my
proportional term the second entry of my
parameters is my integral term so it's
essentially this parameter is K
proportional K integral K derivative
okay D and so what I do is I take the
first element and it's proportional so
there's nothing multiplying it I take
the second element and it's times 1 over
s which is the transfer function for an
integrator and the third term is you
know KD times s that's the transfer
function for a derivative now in MATLAB
it won't let me build a transfer
function and run this control loop with
an actual derivative because that would
be kind of unstable so what I do is I
divide it by 1 plus something really
really really small times s so that at
very very very high frequencies this
derivative term rolls off to zero and
becomes unimportant okay so this is
basically a derivative KD times s and
then normalized by this really really
really high frequency roll-off so this
is basically just actually a high pass
filter a high pass filter with a very
high frequency okay so that's that's
what I'm doing here in this PID test I
take these parameters and I build a PID
control law this last term here is just
a little funky because derivatives are
weird in MATLAB and then what I do is I
build my my open-loop I take my my
system G and my controller K and
I build a series a series I have my
system G I have my controller K and I
build a transfer function from the left
to the right and then what I do is I
feed back on this loop like that okay so
I build this feedback this is just nice
two lines in MATLAB I build a series
than a feedback and then what I do is I
step the system my close loop system and
I see what the step response is I want a
nice fast rise time so when I step the
system I want to go from zero to one as
fast as possible with this little
overshoot and ringing as possible okay
and to quantify that what I'm going to
do is I'm going to use an lqr cost
function
okay so this is my control transfer
function I'm basically and also
simulating I want to know what the
control input was when I give this step
I want to know what my control signal
does because I'm going to penalize
really big control and puts you and so I
build this cost function J which
basically adds up how how long it takes
my state to get to the set point so
basically the error of my tracking
squared times Q plus how expensive it
was u squared times R that's just the
MATLAB way of doing this I take my
vector of outputs and my vector of use
and I dot square them and sum them up so
that basically adds them up over time
okay long story short what I'm doing is
I have this system I want to wrap a
feedback controller a PID controller
around it and I want to tune the
proportional integral and derivative
terms to minimize this lqr cost function
so I want really good state tracking I
want to track this step as fast as
possible with as little error as
possible and I also want to do it with
as little control input u as possible
okay and then I have some plotting
commands here again you can download all
of this and play around with it yourself
but basically I want to actually see
what the step response looks like so we
can plot on the screen for all of these
these tests
okay so almost everything up until this
point has just been setting up the
problem I set up the the transfer
function the input output dynamics that
I'm going to control I set up this
function PID test that actually tests a
PID controller and sees if it was a high
J or a low J i want small j cost
functions those are good controllers and
then the GA command is super simple
I run GA and I basically tell it what
parameter I'm optimizing over so I take
PID test and I wrap it so that it is
only a function of K these three control
parameters and I lock in G and delta T
so now PA the genetic algorithm knows
that all I'm doing is I'm running PID
test and I'm trying to tweak these K
parameters to get the best output of PID
test possible and then there's some
other commands here some other options
that you can you can do the GA help and
see what to do I think basically this is
telling it that you know there's three
variables that's optimizing over it
gives it some initial condition and
things like that
okay so you can you can look into this
yourself I also have an option for an
output function called my fun my
function which basically and every
iteration and every every time you
evaluate an individual and every time
the generation advances I essentially
save some internal variables so that I
can plot them later so I'm in I'm
plotting what is what are the three
control parameters what's the system
response what's the cost function J and
things like that and eventually this
gets dumped into a a file called history
mat so I can load that and after the
fact after I've run this genetic
algorithm I can plot a bunch of things
and diagnose how it learned the right
controller okay
so I kind of just want to recap there's
a system I want to control there is a
function that evaluates a controller and
tells me was it good low J or was it bad
hi J and all I do is I I plug that into
the GA algorithm I tell it
what to optimize this K parameter and it
goes and I have to tell it you know how
many individuals per generation and how
many generations and I run it okay so
I'm gonna hit go and what this is going
to do is you're gonna see a bunch of
step responses plotted to the screen and
down here you're gonna see the cost
function for each of those and we're
just going to run through all of these
ten generations twenty-five individuals
each so we're gonna see two hundred and
fifty control laws step responses and
what we want when we do this step
response in time what we want this is
our set point we're trying to step up
here I want this thing to go up as fast
as possible and stay stay close to the
set point what I don't want is huge
oscillations that take a long time this
would be a big state deviation that
should give me a bad cost function and
what will be even worse this is an
unstable system so if I pick a bad PID
controller what would be even worse is
this this goes unstable okay so that
would be a huge cost function integrated
over ten time units okay
so that's what we're gonna see is these
kind of different canonical step
responses for different PID control
values and then genetic algorithms is
going to optimize okay let's try it out
I think we're ready to go let's hope
there's no errors I'm gonna run this
code okay so very quickly we should be
seeing a bunch of step responses pop up
so these are the step responses these
are the cost functions down here you see
a lot of them were unstable kind of blow
up but some of them are okay and even
after one generation you see many more
of them are going to the set value of
one and not blowing up you still have
some unstable ones but now these cost
functions are already getting a lot
smaller now they're around one point one
or two and only rarely do they get
really big so this from generation to
generation these control laws are
getting better and better and better and
finding better and better
PID control gains and so we're just
going to watch this evolve for a little
bit now you see it's like kind of just
jiggling around these really good
solutions those are the the good
and it's just you know mutating and
crossing over trying to get slightly
more optimal solutions and we found kind
of this you know 1.4 seems like a pretty
good minimum value it's not doing a lot
lower than that okay it's done so super
fast to evaluate if you're if it's if
it's fast to evaluate a control law you
can run through hundreds or thousands of
these things and really find good
optimizing parameters okay let's see
what X and F Val what's X okay X is the
optimizing so this will spit out the
single best K the single best PID gains
those are these and the best optimizing
function value this is my cost function
J so F Val the lowest it ever found was
one point four seven six for these
proportional integral and derivative
terms so if I want I can just run PID
test of G with delta T and this best PID
control gains X these three values here
and this is the best the best response
apparently according to the lqr cost
function according to minimizing the
state deviation and the control cost
this is the best response that genetic
algorithm found okay now I don't know if
this is a particularly good one or bad
one
you can definitely squash down this peak
but it'll take longer to rise and
apparently that costs more according to
my cost function so this is only optimal
with respect to the cost function that
you select and maybe this was a bad cost
function so that's very important is
that these algorithms are no smarter
than how you set the problem up so if
you want different performance then you
need to put in you know put that into
your cost function so if I wanted to
squash this peak down maybe I should put
a penalty on a maximum peak one of the
cool things about genetic algorithms you
know the lqr cost function is is this
quadratic smooth cost function and it
was chosen that way because there are
known optimal closed-form solutions but
with genetic algorithms this can
actually find solutions to non convex
problems so I could put in
constraints on you you can never be
bigger than a value I could put in you
know inequality constraints or I can
basically penalize kind of the maximum
value that this hits any number of
things that would be very hard and non
convex traditionally you can do in
genetic algorithms okay so this is the
best control law that was found pretty
easy to run you know most of the effort
and most of the time was actually just
setting up the problem and the cost
function right running the genetic
algorithm was super fast and simple okay
so in the next video we're going to load
that history map file and actually start
to see what this genetic algorithm did
under the hood okay thank you